Traduttore: Cristina Bufi-Pöcksteiner
Revisore: Sofia Ramundo
Buongiorno a tutti.
Io ringrazio TEDx per l'invito
che mi ha voluto estendere.
E io sono qua,
visto che tra poco sarà l'ora di pranzo,
per parlarvi di qualcosa di originale,
che ha a che fare con la cucina.
Vorrei parlarvi della mia idea
per aprire le noci di cocco.
Allora, noi tutti abbiamo in cucina
decine di attrezzi
per tante, tante funzioni.
E quello che ci manca è qualche cosa
per aprire le noci di cocco.
Quando abbiamo questo problema
bisogna andare non in cucina,
ma a prendere la cassetta degli attrezzi,
cercare un martello, cercare una sega,
o quant'altro, oppure
andare a sbattere la noce
sul pavimento, contro un muro,
quindi sono tutte pratiche non igieniche,
faticose e spesso
anche pericolose,
soprattutto se usiamo una sega o
qualche cosa di questo tipo.
Allora, la mia idea è stata
quella di vedere
che cos'è, com'è fatta
una noce di cocco.
È un seme che deve cadere
da una palma,
da un'altezza tra i 25 e i 30 m,
senza rompersi, ovviamente.
Però, nonostante questo,
ha un punto debole, che è
il punto da dove nasce
la gemma della nuova palma.
Quindi, in natura, da uno dei tre cerchi
che vediamo sul guscio,
uscirà una gemma,
quando la noce è matura,
che darà origine, appunto,
alla nuova palma.
Solo uno dei tre cerchi è attivo ed è
chiamato il "soft eye" in inglese
e per individuarlo
andiamo a,
semplicemente, bussare,
diciamo, su questi tre.
Allora, l'attrezzo che vi presento è
una CoccoCrack, una vite conica
con un'impugnatura,
e andando ad avvitarla
in questo "soft eye", quindi
questo punto debole
vediamo che cosa
dovrebbe succedere.
Allora, andiamo
ad individuare, appunto,
il punto debole della noce,
quindi questo "soft eye",
e cominciamo ad avvitare
la punta in acciaio.
Ci si appoggia su una superficie stabile,
per evitare di perdere la noce,
insomma, di fare dei malanni.
E ogni noce fa storia a sé,
quindi io non so prevedere
come si comporterà questa.
Ne ho altre due in caso, insomma,
abbiamo delle munizioni da sparare.
Allora, fino adesso io ho avvitato
con una forza che è simile
a quella che serve
per avvitare un cavatappi
nel tappo di sughero,
diciamo, di una bottiglia.
Ora vado a incontrare
una resistenza un po' maggiore,
perché sono arrivato a toccare il legno
con la punta del CoccoCrack.
A questo punto continuo ad avvitare.
La forma conica della vite
dovrebbe fare questo.
Non so se si è sentito.
(Applausi)
Ecco, il crack di CoccoCrack.
Allora, continuando ad avvitare,
ecco, andiamo ad avere
una crepa sul guscio.
Una, due, tre, in questo caso
siamo anche stati fortunati.
Possiamo togliere l'acqua e recuperarla
per gli usi successivi, insomma.
Continuando ad avvitare,
si staccano dei pezzi di noce.
E ora questo pezzo,
vedete, è facile poi
staccare la polpa dal guscio,
con un coltello da cucina.
In questo caso, invece, dobbiamo andare
ad utilizzare il secondo attrezzo,
che è una specie di apriscatole,
funziona come un apriscatole.
Inseriamo la lama nella polpa
e andiamo a forzare.
Quindi anche qua si vanno a
staccare dei pezzi in successione,
fino a consentirci di ottenere
delle porzioni di cocco,
sufficientemente piccole
da staccare, appunto,
rapidamente e facilmente la polpa.
Ecco, l'ultima fase
dell'operazione.
Prendere un coltello da cucina e, appunto,
infilarlo tra il guscio e la polpa e,
a questo punto, riusciamo ad
ottenere i nostri pezzi di cocco.
Ecco, questo ...
(Applausi)
Grazie